so andrew cuomo the idiot governor of
new york who's presided over one of the
worst death permillion rates in the
nation
he said yesterday that officers must
must enforce kova 19 laws in fact if you
don't enforce a covenant 19 law and
you're an officer and
you refuse to do it you're a dictator so
i think he doesn't understand
a language that we call english where
dictators are people
like i don't know who who declare
randomly that we should completely shut
down an entire state's school district
for no apparent reason
that seems more dictatorial than an
officer saying i'm not going to enforce
mandates
that seem to me to violate individual
liberties nonetheless according to
andrew cuomo
it's the officers who are the dictators
i believe
that law enforcement officer violates
his or her constitutional duty
i don't consider them a law enforcement
officer
because you don't have the right to pick
laws that you think you will enforce
and you don't enforce laws that you
don't agree with
right that's not a law enforcement
officer
uh that's a dictator a dictator is the
person who decides he doesn't want to
enforce particular somebody should talk
to barack obama about the deferred
action for childhood rivals program
i'm old enough to remember when that guy
declared that he could simply disregard
immigration law because he was a magical
magical man
and he could use his pen in his phone to
magically change law andrew cuomo might
want to talk to that guy about selective
enforcement of law
also the good news for andrew cuomo is
the rules don't apply to him so
he uh he announced actually on monday
that he would be spending thanksgiving
with his 89 year old mother
and his two daughters that was exciting
stuff here was yesterday
the story is my mom is gonna come up
and two of my uh girls
is the current plan but the plans
change um but that's my plan
that was his plan you see so he said you
can't have thanksgiving with your family
you are one of the common folk no
thanksgiving with your family
but you know who can have thanksgiving
with his 89 year old mother and his two
daughters
wait you know what i was told i was
totally intergenerational dinners
that are filled with people eating
turkey in a closed room
that's a bad idea so he's got his 89
year old mom and his two daughters
who last i checked i believe are in
their 20s and they're all in the same
room together
and they're sharing dinner isn't that
nice he's having a thanksgiving guys we
can't begrudge it i mean he's been
working hard
at killing all the old folks in the
state he's been working super hard at
writing a book about how wonderful he is
while people die
he like he won an emmy we cannot
begrudge him his thanksgiving dinner
these standards do not apply to andrew
cuomo okay so he now revised that
later in the day his office issued a
statement clarifying the plans have
changed his senior advisor rich as a
party told the wall street journal given
the current circumstances of the
covenant cuomo will have to work through
thanksgiving oh
that isn't that nice and then nice by
the way he said on sunday quote next
thanksgiving you'll ask yourself did i
do everything i could to keep my
community safe
the rules don't apply if you are a
special if you are a special the rules
simply do not apply to you
it's really exciting stuff that's that's
really really nice and that i mean
if you're andrew cuomo you just can do
whatever the hell you want it's pretty
great if you're one of the commoners
however you just get boned
if you're one of the commoners then they
can do whatever they want to you
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content